[Music]
talk about the Spice Girls
yeah these days you've kind of like
dropped the hint that potentially would
be for me at the royal wedding
you took you craz like a massive fire
stir well no what's the update on them
we signed to Simon full of the original
Spice Girls manager we signed to him a
few months ago okay you were a tiny baby
with when we went on tour and you're
kind of missed out on that my
ten-year-old my six-year-old is like are
you really a Spice Girl is that really
you because I've got some pictures up of
me holding you in the recording studio
my sisters came in a little later are
you gonna get a chance to do it again at
their wedding we will be doing stuff
this year Oh better oh yeah
fingers crossed the Spice Girls slam it
to the left and shake it to the right at
Prince Harry and Megan markle's main
nuptials it'll certainly be a busy month
for mouths she's gearing up for her 6th
season as a judge on America's Got
Talent
she brought her 19 year old daughter
Phoenix to the show's kick-off event in
Pasadena California on Monday I mean
walking the red carpet you hanging out
with your mom because usually I was good
please come to work with me today she
was like yes I really want to what about
with all the celebrity kids going to
modeling there's that something that you
would do would your mom don't you do
that I don't know would you know you
want to do all your fashion sense oh
yeah my passion is for fashion I love
fashion wag she's got cool swag what I
want to do for the rest of my life I
dress her I wish I could your are you
wish you could but you're by the way
this is one of my dresses one wouldn't
dress like this usually or even wear
heels I mean I would if the time comes
in there it is but she's like more of us
she's got her own like swag street style
going on
SWAT is cool you told me that
[Music]